[Music]
sometimes people say that in the absence
of religion there can be no moral values
and in fact that for that reason there
can never be values that everyone agrees
upon we are inherently conflictual the
the human condition is conflict among
people's because they can just never
agree on our values well putting the
light of that our developments like the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights in
1948 and the Millennium Development
Goals where the nations of the world
agreed on a number of milestones that
that humanity should strive for having
to do with health and longevity and
education and some of which were met
years early
such as reduction of extreme poverty
usually defined as more or less what a
person would need to support himself and
his family which was met several years
ahead of schedule right now the less
than ten percent of the world lives in a
state of extreme poverty and the
successor to the Millennium Development
Goals called the sustainable development
goals calls for the elimination of
extreme poverty by the 2030s an
astonishingly gold one that is by no
means out of reach when one development
that people both on the left and the
right are unaware of is that it's almost
ending in external force that leads
affluent societies to devote increasing
amounts of their wealth to social
spending to redistribution to children
to education to health care to support
of the poor to support the agit now
until the 20th century most societies
devoted at most one and a half percent
of their GDP to social spending and
generally much less than that but
starting in the 30s with the New Deal in
the United States and accelerating in
Europe after World War two with the
welfare state now the median across
societies of social spending is 22
percent of GDP
the United States is a little bit below
that but even that's misleading because
we've got a lot of welfare that's done
by our by our employers that's how we
get our health insurance that's how we
get our retirement other countries it's
the government that that mediates that
but if you add the private social
spending onto the public portion United
States is actually second-highest of the
entire world but this is a development
sometimes called Wagner's law and it
just seems that resistance is futile
even conservative politicians like
george w bush presided over another
expansion of the welfare state with this
medicare drug benefit and the attempts
by the trump administration to repeal
obamacare for example we're stymied by
pitchfork and and and torch barring
angry constituents people like social
spending despite their protestations
even in libertarian america and in fact
the it's probably not a coincidence that
the number of libertarian paradises in
the world that is developed states with
no substantial social spending is zero
and as developing countries develop as
they start to become affluent they get
on the bandwagon and they start to
develop programs of social spending the
expansion of social spending shouldn't
be a shock because even if one believes
in the principles of the free market
then they're just some things that the
market is not going to provide by design
no one expects that the market will
provide for poor children it's not
something that markets can do or the
elderly or the unlucky people with
nothing to offer in the marketplace in
exchange for which they can make a
decent living and so as a kind of
necessary patch or Cluj or as we say
safety net wealthy societies have to
provide what the market by design cannot
[Music]